encuentre los valores de escena de teta
y con seno de teta para teta igual a 23
200 34 pie entre 3 y 5 cliente 3
asumiendo que todos estos valores se
encuentran
en radiales
radiantes
calculemos estos elementos usando
nuestro círculo unitario aquí está la
vamos a colocar más o menos
aquí
a tener buen espacio y vamos a usar
nuestras definiciones de razones
trigonométricas ya que esto no lo
podemos resolver usando zocato ah pues
algunos de estos ángulos van a ser
mayores a 90 grados o incluso van a ser
ángulos negativos ya que tenemos nuestro
circle' unitario para visualizar mejor
estos ángulos con nuestro conocimiento
de triángulos vamos a convertir todos
estos ángulos de radiales a grados
comencemos por el primero el de pi entre
entre 3 radiales
para convertir los sagrados lo
multiplicó por 180 grados
/
radiales
irradian es entre pi radian es todo esto
se va a anular y nos queda ciento 180
grados entre 3 180 entre 3 va a ser
igual a 60 grados
60 grados este es el primer ángulo así
que este primer ángulo va a ser igual
60 grados
el siguiente ángulo
vamos a hacerlo en un color un poquito
más brillante
el siguiente ángulo es 2 p entre 3 es
dos veces este valor de acá pues si es
dos veces este valor
este valor es 60 grados 2 por 60 va a
ser 120 pero vamos a calcularlo de esta
manera para que veamos que efectivamente
comprobemos que ese es el valor es 2
entre 3 radiales
radian es
igual 180 grados lo voy a abreviar grass
entre y abrevió también los radiales
pre step y radiant es se va con este de
aquí los radiales también se van me
queda 2% 80 son 360 entre 3 va a ser
igual a 120 grados 120 grados
este
otro ángulo va a ser igual a 120
cambiamos de color veamos el siguiente
ángulo que es 4 p / 3
cuatro veces este ángulo 6 por 4 24 será
240 pero de todas maneras lo hacemos
aquí para comprobar que efectivamente
estamos calculando lo correctamente y
aquí en lugar de escribir un 2 debo
escribir un 44 pi
entre 3 radiales
a 180 lo multiplicó por 180 radiales
entre pide perdón 180 grados 180 grados
entre y radiales
porque esto de 180 grados en tepic
radiales es lo mismo es una es una
unidad es lo mismo que multiplicarlo por
1 por eso es que lo puedo hacer sin
modificarlo sin cambiarle su valor así
que es se van a este pin y este radial
este pille esther díaz se van 4 por
ciento 80 entre 3 nos va a dar igual a
este ángulo
240 y finalmente 5 pi entre 3 vamos a
elegir un color rosa
5 pin radian es entre 3 lo multiplicamos
por 180
y siempre quiero ponerle bienes no son
grados
a 2
/ p
radiales
esto que va a ser igual pues va a ser
cinco veces estos cinco por seis treinta
300 grados de todas maneras lo
comprobamos este se va con este este
radio se va con este 5% 80 entre 3
efectivamente nos va a dar 300 grados el
último ángulo es de 300 grados
y ya que convertimos todos los ángulos a
grados que al menos para mí los hace
mucho más fácil de visualizar
procederemos a dibujar estos ángulos en
nuestro círculo unitario para encontrar
sus senos y cosenos correspondientes
primero vamos a dibujar al de 60 grados
nuestro ángulo va a iniciar desde este
punto
que estoy dibujando aquí para más bien
desde esta línea nuestro ángulo va a
iniciar aquí y va a hacer un ángulo
positivo de 60 grados es decir va a ir
hacia acá no en línea no lo voy a usar
líneas hacia acá positivo y va a
recorrer si estos son 90 grados pues son
dos tercios de esta cantidad entonces
esta línea va a ir más o menos por acá
por lo que este ángulo va a terminadas
más o menos
aquí recuerden que el seno de theta y el
coseno de teta van a ser las coordenadas
de este punto de intersección aquí en
este punto vamos a tener las coordenadas
coseno de bueno no se detecta que el
ángulo es de 60 grados coseno de 60
grados
en el seno de 60 grados es las
coordenadas de este punto de
intersección entre el ángulo y la
circunferencia este es un ángulo de 60
grados y vamos a transformar este ángulo
en un triángulo rectángulo para hacer
esto pues voy a dejar una línea que baje
directamente de este punto de
intersección y sea perpendicular a mi
eje
va a quedar así este es un ángulo de 90
grados y si tenemos un ángulo de 60
grados
uno de 90 pues este ángulo restante va a
ser de 30 grados nos queda un triángulo
de 30 60 90 y vamos a recordar
rápidamente las propiedades de estos
triángulos
imaginemos que de este lado vamos a
tener un triángulo equilátero
más o menos
lo mejor que puedo en un triángulo
equilátero todos sus ángulos y todos sus
lados van a ser iguales así que este va
a ser ya que sabemos que todos los
ángulos internacion triángulo tienen que
sumar 180 grados pues de estos tres aquí
vamos a tener tres ángulos iguales de 60
grados 60 grados 60 grados
qué pasa si dividimos este ángulo de
aquí arriba a la mitad justo así
pues me van a quedar dos triángulos que
son simétricos el ángulo de aquí arriba
de ser 60 pues como lo divide a la mitad
van a ser treinta y treinta aquí voy a
tener un ángulo recto
de 90 grados
en ambos lados de estos triángulos y
algo que me pasó decirles este triángulo
equilátero cada uno de sus lados mide
uno tiene la longitud de uno así que al
partir por la mitad este lado vamos a
tener aquí un medio de este lado y otro
medio de este otro lado al usar el
teorema de pitágoras la longitud de este
otro lado de aquí este lado de aquí que
estoy señalando con una flecha va a
valer raíz de 3
un medio
o lo que es lo mismo raíz de 3 / 2
eso es todo lo que necesitamos saber
sobre los triángulos 30 60 90 regresando
a nuestro círculo unitario cuál es la
longitud de la hipotenusa de este
triángulo que acabo de dibujar bueno
recordamos que es un círculo unitario
por lo que el radio va a valer 1 y esta
longitud de aquí acá es un radio así que
esto vale 1 y aplicando lo que acabamos
de ver aquí sí tenemos este triángulo de
30 60 90 grados con la hipotenusa de 1
pues este lado de aquí esto esta
longitud va a valer un medio y esta de
aquí arriba que lo voy a poner en otro
color
de este lado
va a valer raíz de 3
entre 2 y esto que nos dice bueno esta
longitud en x este es nuestro eje x y
este es nuestro eje i
nos indica aquí este es la coordenada x
de este punto de intersección y esta
coordenada o esta longitud equivale a la
coordenada engine de este punto de
intersección y ahora regresando a la
pregunta cuál es el coste no de 60
grados recordando que son las
coordenadas x excusión es de 60 grados y
la coordenada que va a ser el seno de 60
grados escribimos
jose no de 60 grados qué bueno
recordamos lo que no se especificaban al
inicio realmente comenzamos con el
coseno del ángulo theta cuando este
ángulo es igual a entre 3 radiales
coseno de pi entre 3 radiales que es lo
mismo que el coseno de 60 grados va a
ser igual a
nuestra coordenada x un medio
la misma lógica el seno
de ping entre 3 radiales que es igual al
seno
lo escribo mejor
de 60 grados va a ser igual a raíz de 3
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2 bueno ahora
vamos a revisar lo mismo pero para
nuestro segundo ángulo que es de 120
grados a este ángulo que tenemos acá de
60 vamos a agregarle otro ángulo de 60
grados vamos a movernos y es ponerlo con
otro color vamos a elegir un color
también que se destaque
ahora mi ángulo va a comenzar igual a
partir de aquí pero en lugar de ser de
60 ahora va a ser de 120 grados 120
grados y va a terminar
aproximadamente
vamos a calcular las coordenadas de este
otro punto de intersección pues vamos a
dibujar otro triángulo rectángulo vamos
a dibujarlo con una línea recta y lo
vamos a dibujar de este punto de
intersección directamente hacia abajo
hasta tocar el eje
ok aquí tenemos nuestro triángulo
rectángulo cuál será el ángulo restante
o también llamado ángulo de referencia
que es el ángulo que se encuentra del
eje horizontal el eje de las equis hacia
este ángulo permíteme de dibujarlo un
poco mejor cuál será este ángulo que
resta de aquí el ángulo de referencia
si nos tomó 120 grados llegar aquí
de un lado al otro son 180 grados el
restante va a ser 60 grados 60 más 120
va igual a 180
aquí tenemos nuevamente un triángulo 30
bueno este va a ser 90 este 60 y aquí no
queda más que ser de 30 el ángulo
restante 30 grados
nuestro triángulo es 30 60 90 y dado que
conocemos que esta hipotenusa va a ser
unitaria va a valer 1 este lado de acá
pues aplicamos lo mismo que conocemos de
los triángulos 30 60 90
el lado opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados
va a valer
raíz de 3 entre 2 entonces el lado
opuesto a este ángulo es decir este va a
tener
una longitud de raíz cuadrada de 3 entre
2 y el lado opuesto al ángulo de 30
grados que es este el lado más chico va
a medir un medio
esta es la longitud todavía no estamos
considerando la dirección basándonos en
esto que acabamos de definir cuáles
serán las coordenadas de este punto de
acá
la coordenada x es un medio pero en el
lado negativo del eje será menos un
medio aquí va a ser menos un medio y la
coordenada y pues será aquí
la que coincida con este eje y que viene
siendo raíz de 3 entre 2 positivo raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 2
esta es la coordenada de este punto de
intersección por lo tanto para el ángulo
theta cuando vale 2 pi entre 3
el coseno de dos pies
entre 3 que es igual al coseno
de 120 grados va a ser igual a la
coordenada x que es menos un medio
lo mismo el seno de 2 y entre 3 que es
igual al seno
120 grados es igual en este caso
coincide con el anterior raíz cuadrada
de 3 positivo entre 2
ahora continuamos con el siguiente
ángulo 4 entre 3
que queramos que son 240 grados para
dibujar este ángulo lo que voy a hacer
es
parto de este lado inicial y voy a tener
aquí hasta aquí tengo 180 grados para
llegar a 240 necesito agregar 60 grados
aquí así que mi terminador del ángulo va
a quedar aproximadamente
por acá
este va a ser mi ángulo de 240
lo escribo aquí 240 grados este ángulo
que estoy dibujando en verde oscuro
bueno vamos a encontrar las coordenadas
de intersección de este punto
lo mismo que hicimos en las veces
anteriores vamos a dibujar un triángulo
rectángulo a partir de este punto de
intersección una línea que va
perpendicular al eje de las equis y aquí
queda mi triángulo rectángulo este va a
ser mi ángulo
90 grados este ángulo de acá el ángulo
de referencia que es el que tenemos con
respecto al eje horizontal va a ser de
60 grados es lo que agregamos a estos
180 grados para tener un total de 240
por lo tanto nuevamente tenemos un
triángulo 30 60 90 este ángulo tiene que
ser de 30 grados para que a sumarlos con
60 grados y 90 grados nos dé los 180
grados que debe tener la suma de los
ángulos de un triángulo de nuevo sabemos
cuáles son las proporciones ya que esta
longitud de la hipotenusa sigue siendo 1
es un radio del círculo unitario por lo
tanto a ver digan conmigo el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados va a
valer raíz de 3 entre 2 y el lado
opuesto a 30 grados va a valer un medio
de hecho aquí lo tengo en amarillo de la
medición anterior pero sigue siendo este
valor ahora tomando en cuenta si estamos
del lado negativo de los ejes tanto la
es de 3 entre 2 un medio van a estar del
lado negativo aquí este es menos raíz de
3 entre 2 y aquí sigue siendo menos un
medio la coordenada en este punto va a
ser
- un medio y la parte de la coordenada
es menos raíz cuadrada menos raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 2 así que nuestras
razones el coseno
el ángulo de 4
entre 3 que es igual al coseno de 240
grados es igual a menos un medio
el seno
de 4 pin entre 3
es igual al seno de 240 grados
y este va a ser igual a menos raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 2
nada más nos queda un último ángulo que
analizar nuestro último ángulo es el de
5 entre 3 radiales que es igual a 300
grados
comenzamos desde este punto como hemos
comenzado todos los demás ángulos
llegamos hasta aquí hasta los 270 grados
que es en este eje y le agregamos 30
grados más para alcanzar los 300 grados
mi ángulo de 300 grados va a terminar
aproximadamente
acá
creo que a estas alturas ustedes ya
pueden imaginar qué es lo que voy a
hacer
efectivamente voy a dibujar un triángulo
rectángulo a partir de esta intersección
en línea recta perpendicular a mi eje de
las x aquí está mi triángulo rectángulo
tengo aquí mi ángulo de 90 grados aquí
este ángulo de referencia va a ser de 60
grados y por supuesto el restante es de
30 grados
nuevamente ustedes ya lo saben el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados va a
valer raíz de 3 entre 2
la hipotenusa es de 1 es el radio y el
lado más chico vale un medio
entonces las coordenadas aquí x lo
tenemos del lado positivo va a ser un
medio
como ya lo tenemos del lado negativo del
eje y va a ser menos raíz de 3 entre 2
nuestras últimas razones trigonométricas
el seno de 5 pin entre 3 igual al seno
de 300 grados
nos resulta que es menos raíz de 3
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2 y el coseno
la coordenada x de 5 pi entre 3 coseno
de 300 grados igual a un medio